احكام الاعدام بحق المحتاجين في ايران لن
تتوقف لا بل ستتصاعد وبقوه فالنظام
الايرانيه سعى بكل جهوده لوقف الاحتجاجات
او تخفيف وترتها على الاقل افادت مصادر
ايرانيه بان السلطات تستعد لتنفيذ حكم
اعدام ثاني بحق احد الموقوفين في سجن رجال
شهر ويدعى مهان صدرك وسط استمرار ردود
الافعال الغاضبه من اعدام المحتاج
الايراني محسن شكاري في طهران وحذرت منظمه
العفو الدوليه من خطر اعدام الشاب معان
بعد شهر واحد فقط من محاكمته في محكمه
الثوره جاء هذا التحذير بعد ما نقلت
السلطات مهام من سجن طهران الكبير الى سجن
رجال شهر استعدادا لتنفيذي حكم الاعدام
وقالت اسرته انها تلقت بلاغا بان الحكم
الصادر ضد ابنها دخل مرحله التنفيذ من
جانبها كشفت منظمه هارانا الحقوقيه عن
صدور حكم الاعدام على احد معتقلين
احتجاجات في مدينه مشهد شمال شرقي ايران
ويدعى مجيد رضا
رهنه طبعا قرار الاعدامات هذا ياتي كدليل
واضح على تاثر النظام الايراني سواء
سياسيا او حتى اقتصاديا فالعمله الايرانيه
خسرت المزيد من قيمتها امام الدولار
الامريكي يبلغ سعر صرف الدولار حوالي
370,000 ريال ايراني